well that that generator hello everybody
my name is markiplier and welcome to
Sophie's curse now I just got in the
game here because oh oh oh this is not
what I thought it would be okay I got
this game on Steam and when I opened it
up I had no idea what it was going to be
about it oh [ __ ] oh my god that's so
weird it's like an old Miss style game
it's like something made from the 90s so
apparently the story is that I am taking
care of some old sleeping grandpa and
that's him in the bed there that him so
apparently in this house there's four
lighting devices if that's even a thing
and I have to keep them charged Oh what
the hell how do I get to be I don't know
how to get to be how the Frick do I get
to be to be or not to what the [ __ ] is
happening who's that oh my god what's
going on that's a bunch Oh humming how
do I get - oh that's B oh okay I got B
buzz buzz at a complete loss for what
the hell is going on okay so the story
is you're
you're hired for some gig a job to take
care of an old man who's sleeping in the
middle of night and all son you're
running at breakneck speed through this
house trying to keep these lights on and
the generator running cuz holy hell it
couldn't be any more logical than this
hey grandpa how you doing doing nice you
good whoa
is there a ghost in this house right now
or is that the wind whipping through my
hair okay see this is bizarre this is
something that I've never seen in the
game in the past 20 years
like the click to move around the place
kind of style thing but it's cool like I
like it I can dig it I'm wondering
what's gonna happen when I left
when I let one of the power sources go
down so as an experiment I'm just gonna
let be run is there a ghost
should I be concerned
okay I think I get the gist of the
controls check the computer for some
goddamn reason
okay so as a safe point
what a save point mean is that yeah boo
boo I made it I don't know
hello there a message or something I got
to a checkpoint and there's a safe point
at a now I don't know what that means
maybe grandpa moved down here to just
take a little nap hi hello what what the
[ __ ] oh god I thought that was a safe
point
oh god what do I do
what what the [ __ ] is happening what the
[ __ ] I don't know I just thought random
screaming would help me out
uh-huh okay
all righty then anybody else in this
house of hell wanna tell me what's up
grandpa grandpa grandpa there's certain
thing in the house and apparently wants
to kill me maybe I don't know for sure
hard to say and apparently there's still
a problem with a how do I fix the
problem with a what do I do
oh do I just keep cranking this yank
until it just gives up on me give me the
puddin give me the candy make the jack
pop out of the box no what do you want
for me all righty then it's gonna surf
porn on the computer I know there's an
error Oh what is that
why oh oh
okay what [ __ ] okay try that again I
didn't know that I was supposed to do a
big old dang ol puzzle and if one light
goes out some one that name of Sophie is
gonna come murder your face off rip your
face off put it on her face so that she
can enjoy a little face action uh face
on face sexytimes all right let's try
this again
not that I know exactly what I'm doing
but I have a general idea now that I
need to repair these devices grandpa
grandpa
thoughts not good sounds I know good
sounds when I hear them goes not that
whatever I ain't choosy anyway back to
my porn
I'll get what same coin
what I can think about it for the Frick
was that
well that not generate why why what did
I do
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] man
why the bog hagensen don't let the
lights run out it I didn't read this
Sophie can be pretty mean you save
points whatever you're in a save point
means nothing can happen to you unless
the doula what oh god oh man if you're
charging a device and Sophie makes a
creepy sound it means she's behind you
stop charging immediately wow I should
have read those instructions good god
that's a little finicky don't you think
alright let's give this another go see
if I could do a little better so if I
hear any creepy sound she's behind me
breathing on the nape of my neck giving
me giving me gentle smooches ever so
gently then she screams and rips my face
off but that comes after the gentle
smooches all right so I need to check
the computer to make sure we're the safe
for you
savepoints indeed grandpa's room nothing
bad can happen to me up there mm-hmm
okay I like this is good this is the
things that I like the most about life
breathing walking around looking at porn
yelling at grandpa eating a papaya
fixing a tire getting out of bed
masturbating other things I like about
life looking at paintings [ __ ] that
didn't sound good sounds like someone
might have broke in and trying to eat my
face off all right
okay
okay got it there's someone crying
nearby don't like that that ain't good
I'm gonna go back up to the safe zone
nothing bad can happen to me in the safe
zone yeah dude
safe zone I love the safe zone grandpa
you're in the safe zone you know what's
going on
well you know I gotta try that didn't
seem very safe I'm in my safety zone
you can't penetrate my bubble of
safeness I've got triple layered condoms
on for no reason I'm so safe you think
you can even get your clothes the answer
is you cannot let me make sure my safe
zone is still in the proper safety zone
yep still is I'll go back up some [ __ ]
[ __ ] for [ __ ] sake man for [ __ ] dick
high well to do run away oh no I don't
want to play sometimes so he likes to
appear at locations learn these
locations try not to look at them for
too long if your peers run the opposite
way oh that would be helpful
hahaha god damn it try this one more
time I'm gonna give it one more go and
then I'm gonna take a second to learn
how to play before I play anymore for
you guys oh man all right where's my
safe zone up with Grandpa I love being
with grandpa keep him a man man he's my
papaw my papaw gonna be with me forever
just go stand here and enjoy the sounds
of rain and thunder and the sounds of
crap hitting the insides of my
underpants
I'm not massaging climate in here
Oh teddy sprinkles come on back what did
I do
I did nothing what did I to the one
pound the balls ah good golly Sophie
right that wasn't a legitimate try that
was not a legitimate try I don't know
what the hell happened there but that
was not a legitimate try Sophie is just
such a dick back up with grandpa still
the safe point so I'm gonna go straight
there and I'm not gonna dick with nobody
[ __ ] this till the first thing breaks
then I die right grandpa first thing it
breaks on you you just keel over and die
good lordy well that's not good sounds
that action there there there there five
six nine oh [ __ ] [ __ ] zero hold on we're
good okay back to the safe zone [ __ ]
this [ __ ] I'm out
oh [ __ ] this [ __ ] I'm out oh yeah [ __ ]
this [ __ ] I'm out
let's get out here [ __ ] this [ __ ] I'm
out Hogan again gonna die gonna die
gonna die gonna die why is it done
surging oh god she's gonna kill me
not the ear there go there charge why
was it not charging me yes you know my
dying mother died my mother died
anybody oh god ow ow he gonna get it get
charged anyone charge it's done charging
oh god why am i down to my safe zone
hello goodbye Oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] this I'm go to the safe
zone oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you no go to the safe zone Oh God
hey alright okay nice I live for
another day I get to continue my
pathetic pitiful existence all right
got it all that ain't good that ain't
good
where's the safe zone I don't know [ __ ]
me god that's not the safe zone I'm
trying to get to the safe zone oh well
nevermind then I guess I was like well
they comply right about here [ __ ] well
okay I worded it who do who did it it a
new paint safe zone I don't feel very
safe I don't feel very safe okay holy
[ __ ] what is that sound
that's a new sound of badness I don't
get a checkpoint til 10 I think I gotta
survive until ten holy [ __ ] boy I didn't
expect this game to actually get me like
it just seemed like a you know generally
one of those in the horror games I had
no idea about this game before I got
into it holy crap I was sorely mistaken
oh boy
yeah
turn it up
for some reason this one just doesn't
work that just it just doesn't charge
can save something still D so I'm just
gonna go up there right now forget this
maybe if I just stand I didn't know that
into it but endured a minute if Jun
nothing can happen to me oh it is dark
but I was in the safe zone
you said nothing could happen oh man oh
that got me okay that's all for this
episode I'm gonna try this again this is
actually pretty interesting but in the
next episode I'll make sure that I
actually keep it very dark and dork in
my room so that I get the full
atmosphere treatment so thank you
everybody someone for watching let me
know what better way I can approach this
game and you can play this game for
yourself it's on Steam I forget how much
cost but it links in the description
thanks again everybody and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
Jesus Oh son of a [ __ ] nothing happen
on the tape and something happened right
there at the same time
Oh time to pill good let me just shimmy
my way over to the door